terre de jeux paris 2024 saint quentin
en yvelines se prépare à accueillir les
jo avec cinq épreuves sur son territoire
l'agglomération s'est lancé dans une
recherche active de bénévoles l'idée
c'est que tout le monde peut être
bénévole dès lors qu'il a plus de 18 ans
pour être exact qu'il aura plus de 18
ans le 1er janvier 2000 24 que la
personne en question par le français et
où l'anglais ça aussi c'est une mode de
sélection bien entendu que la personne
soit bien entendu disponible pendant la
période des jeux olympiques mais
également paralympiques puis ensuite
double inscriront sur sa tombe
d'événements tests qui permettront de
lui montrer à la fois ce que l'on
attendait de voir si elle en adéquation
avec les différents rôles que l'on pu le
confier le comité d'organisation des
jeux olympiques paris 2024 à réserver
1000 places pour les habitants de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines les volontaires auront pour
mission d'accueillir les spectateurs les
athlètes les journalistes ou encore
d'aider à l'organisation aux transports
ou aux services médicaux jean paul s'est
porté volontaire pour lui c'était
évident parce que je suis un ancien
sportif et que aujourd'hui je ne peux
plus pratiqués pour des raisons diverses
et variées et que j'ai envie d'aider le
monde sportif j'ai envie d'aider les
jeunes survie de promouvoir
max tout cet esprit sportif que
j'entretiens tout m'a dit j'aimerais
bien voir une belle épreuve amateur du
vélodrome mais bon si je suis pas choisi
ben j'accepterai quand même c'est ça le
la mentalité du bénévole pas de date
limite les inscriptions se termineront
quand le chiffre des 1000 bénévoles sera
attend cependant ne tardez pas car il
reste 300 places de son côté la ville de
montigny le bretonneux a aussi décidé de
s'impliquer dans la recherche de
volontaires la commune s'est fixé pour
objectif de recruter 3 130 bénévoles